Giants beat reporter Paul Schwartz has
been doing a long time for the New York
Post and he joins us now Paul thanks for
joining us
whose decision will this be with that
number to pick overall in the building
hey Dan well it's the Giants always work
at a system where the general manager
has final say but as John mater the
co-owner always reminds everybody it's
ownership that really has final say-so
the you know a six-round seventh round
pick for a linebacker or a cornerback
the general manager will have final
saying no question for the second pick
in this draft it will be Dave
gentleman's decision with a nod to
ownership to say okay yes or no when do
you think you'll get a better sense of
who the Giants are taking what time will
the second pick on Thursday night 8:30
maybe I I think I have a decent sense uh
you know I can't say set and sown sense
but you know look with the second pick
there's only one guy they can't pick
right yes but do you feel let's say
we're betting a week's pay you put up a
week's pay on who you think they're
taking my week's pay or your week spend
your week's pay my weeks pay okay so I
can roll the dice here I don't think
they're taking a quarterback i I've
maintained for a while it they don't
feel these quarterbacks are worth that
number to pick nobody they love so if I
would have to bet a week's pay I would
say Seiko and Barkley they love the guy
they think he can help rejuvenate Eli
Manning's career and let's not forget
their head coach is an offensive guy Pat
Shermer who loves running backs who can
catch the ball how much do you factor in
Eli Manning's future feelings with
whoever you take I think you factor in
everything and and yes but but let's
face it they are committed to Eli so I
don't think they're factoring in Eli's
feelings as far as if we take a
quarterback at number two now Eli is
gonna be hurt by this look they hurt Eli
big-time last year by saying you're not
playing in the second half and he said
no thanks and he was benched and his you
know 210 game consecutive starting
streak ended but they
committed to him Dave Gala meet his new
Pat Shermer is new
they both reviewed all these tapes and
films and said we can go forward with
Eli so what I think the factor is with
Eli is they want to enhance everything
around him they've improved the
offensive line that Nate's older now if
they can get him to start running back
Odell Beckham comes back now you've got
a pretty good offense cooking Dez Bryant
factor in to this at all no he does not
I don't believe they're interested in
Dez Bryant even though they've cut
Brandon Marshall one did not have
anything to do with the other I looked
at the Giants and I agree with you I
think say Kwan Barkley makes the most
sense because this is a team that was
built to win last year failed miserably
with injuries but you know I still look
at them and you put Berkeley in that
lineup and I got all my skilled position
guys aside from my quarterback under the
age of 25 I'm good to go
as long as that defense can kind of hold
up its end of the bargain your thoughts
on that oh I agree totally totally look
put it this way let's face it
Odell Beckham played five games last
year and with four games and was not
really himself in any of them
so you are adding this great receiver to
the offense that exponentially improves
the whole offense so put it this way you
have Odell Beckham lined up white on one
side you can put Barkley anywhere you
can put them in a backfield in the slot
out wide so you pick your poison dealing
with those two guys and oh by the way
sterling Shepherd running around in the
slot and Evan Engram who's one of the
better pass catching tight ends already
in the league with an improved offensive
line yes I think look there was
malpractice what they did to Eli last
year with that offense around him and so
now you give him all these weapons I
think you'll see a much different Eli
Manning man and then you have new
ownership or a new front office here and
and you know that this is the lying
season the last couple of weeks has been
The Lying seasons like nobody wants to
tell you the truth but I give the Giants
credit that they haven't really shown
anything here how does that differ from
other years with the Giants well in the
past sometimes you could get some leaks
not some jerry reach the general manager
but around
that kind of gave you a sense but I
think Dave gentlemen has given some
clues you know he has put such a high
premium on this number to pick saying it
has to be a guy you can visualize
wearing a gold jacket meaning being a
hall-of-famer and it has to be a guy who
has not only worth the second pick in
this draft but in any draft and by those
measurables I don't think they're
looking at quarterbacks in that realm
they're looking at Bradley chub in that
realm say Quan Barclay in that realm
quitting Nelson in that realm although I
do not think they will take a guard
number two so they want a guy who is
going to be a great player with almost
no ifs and buts and they don't look at
the quarterbacks in my view as that guy
any chance they trade gentlemen doesn't
have a history of doing this but any
chance that to pick is for sale yeah
gentlemen in five years with the
Panthers has never traded down but he's
also never had the second pick I think
there is a chance yes I think if if Sam
darn old is not taken number one and now
teams are ravenous to go up and get Sam
darn old I think Elliman would entertain
a trade down but not too far I don't
think he would go all the way down to 12
with the bills but if there's a double
jump there and he can go down to four
five or six and get Berkeley Chubb or
Nelson and also get extra first-round
and a second-round pick out of it then
you're golden then I think he does it
Paul great stuff we'll be reading in the
post here as we lead up to the draft and
I think you're right we're probably not
going to get a sense what the Giants are
doing until they're on the clock thanks
for joining us anytime thank you Dan
that's Paul Schwartz see a Giants beat
writer for the New York Post for more
Dan Patrick show to the audience channel
239 on DirecTV or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]